the minutephysics videos are most pretty
self-explanatory I make I explain
physics in minute long videos and I draw
stick figures a lot of popular ideas
like the earth is flat turned out to be
wrong and a lot of uncomfortable ideas
like quantum mechanics evolution and
plate tectonics turned out to be right I
have a master's degree in physics and
and I'm here at the Perimeter Institute
now and I can just go down the hallway
and ask any of numerous professional
physicists any question I want so but
most the time I do write the scripts I'm
on my own I do calculations I'll do I'll
try to figure things out and then I just
go to make sure I have admitting stupid
mistakes
your your symbol you've got cool you
know it's on Twitter it's on you yeah
tell me better all right let me assure
to show you the symbol please alright
here we go so there's a P surrounded by
an Omega so the real story was that uh
that I originally called it one minute
physics and Omega starts off you know
and Omega seems like an appropriate
letter for that it was om was the start
of Omega and the ohm is the universe is
since I was represented by Omega so I
said well I'll take a pea for physics
and surrounded by Omega and it kind of
looks cool has somebody told me it
looked like a salamander one time like a
head and stuff but really I didn't
really think about it that much and then
eventually when I when I actually
started the YouTube channel I don't want
to put myself in so much of a box that
it's one minute physics oh I said I'll
call it minute physics and then people
can interpret minute as meaning you know
an order of magnitude of one minute so
it could be anywhere from 10 seconds to
10 minutes roughly pairs of electrons
and protons no longer had the energy to
resist each other it started because I
was I was trying to explain some
research that I was actually doing that
I had done during my Master's on general
relativity to a bunch of undergrads and
I realized that the easiest way for me
to explain this was to draw some
pictures and draw you know stick figures
and and and I've always been interested
in filming video so I ended up just
combining the two but it is visible to
radios and radio telescopes and even
makes up a small portion of the salt and
pepper on an analog TV at the beginning
it was totally for fun really I just
made videos as interesting as I thought
they could be and it was much more about
having fun making videos and sharing
awesome the awesomes of science with
people not you know wanting to be
successful on YouTube I thought that
that other part was more important and
if if it was good enough and if people
liked it then it would come eventually
one of the things that I think can be
really confusing and detrimental in
science videos is when you actually have
too many details and too much flashy
fancy special effects or whatever it is
I'd much rather have somebody be you
know have somebody feel like I'm sitting
there next to them showing them this
thing on a piece of paper which is then
if I were actually sitting next to them
show me on a piece of paper I might go
into more details but I because I could
answer questions about it when I'm
making videos that just seemed more
appropriate to to go for the core
essence and ignore the details so like
that's what physicists do really I think
that's why physicists sometimes they're
different from scientists and other
areas
physicists when you need the details you
put them back in but most the time you
try to get away from the details and get
the big picture it's like if you have a
jug with three cups of water in it it's
easy to tell that there are three cups
of water but which is the first cup
right now I'm sitting next to my light
box or light tent what I want to call it
I think it's a light cube anyway I
didn't start off with this I started off
with like some white walls in the corner
of a bedroom and some white tagboard and
and actually these same work lights you
know these are just like five-dollar
work lights from a hardware store
they're not anything professional this
is the only professional aspect of it
and I have a camera that I've put up
here facing down it's just a still
camera in fact it's broken like the
memory card reader doesn't work so I
have to connect it to my computer to
download the images like and so I just
take one picture every second while I'm
drawing and that's what we mean when we
say that we live in three spatial
dimensions and one time dimension okay
so this pile here is it's just where I
put all the finished so I don't know why
there's music there this pile here is
where I put all the finished drawings
once I've done them so I hear some video
or some drawings from the videos about
what this about oh this is about the
standard model and there's you know the
theory of everything so it's reasonable
to think that you might need a lot more
than just one equation to describe it
all and so yeah I just have this huge
all my drawings right I do it on paper I
don't people think I do this on
whiteboards I do it on paper and so I'm
stuck with all these I mean I'm stuck
with them I like to have all these
drawings now and I can at some point I
might do something with them at the
moment I just have them so this isn't
even close to all the drawings this is
just since I've been here at the
Perimeter Institute in February so the
first half the first half a year ago at
physics is in a pile over there and it
was how the room so this is my this is
my sound booth right now there's a
there's a helium-filled shark floating
over it which normally is not there but
you cannot so I sit in here and I have a
microphone and a script and normally
what I do is I have another one of these
cubicle walls that I just slide in front
so it's the sound is really dead and I
sit and I talk and I say something like
dear universe I'm a big fan of yours
you're so fresh and real and I love how
you manage to be fascinating day in and
day out I'm particularly impressed by
your devotion to the laws of nature and
how you stick to them regardless of
opinion polls of scientists or the
public so that's that's pretty much what
I do and I make a lot of mistakes and I
go through and I edit it like crazy
drawing is so quick I mean I draw stick
figures how long does it take a drastic
figure you know you just once the the
big the big
part is writing the script and takes
forever to write a script and once I
have the script is someplace where I
feel like it's really good and I'll read
it aloud while I'm writing it so I can
hear what it sounds like and then once
it's once it's done I'll print it off
and bring it in here and record it and
then I go back and edit the sound once I
finished the script and recorded the
sound only then do I even start to
storyboard out the drawings and that the
storyboarding process takes maybe an
hour for an average minute video and
then the drawing process if I don't have
any special effects the drawings
actually only also take an hour for a
minute video and then I edit them in and
that takes maybe another hour so it's
really quick the drawing the whole
section of drawings is fairly quick
although some of it is because when I'm
writing the script I do you have
pictures going through my head but I
just never write them down because I
don't have to I don't have to
communicate that to anybody else at that
point do you ever want to be doing it
there do you ever when you're talking
about the einsteins of the world do you
think you know what I wish I was
cracking the nuts rather than explaining
the nuts oh that's a really good
question um yeah there are definitely
times when I wish I were still doing
physics research but I'm here surrounded
by so many awesome people doing really
interesting work that I can go and hear
about it what normally happens when I
feel like I wanted to be doing work is I
come upon a really interesting question
and I'll say instead of the beauty the
beautiful thing about physics is once I
think of an interesting question I'll
just go home and try to figure it out
and I might spend like a day or two
working on something and sometimes I get
an answer if it's an easy question
sometimes it's a hard question I've I
get nowhere but I actually still do that
and some sometimes it even comes out and
ends up being in video pick a few
elementary particles set them on a high
energy collision course and bam for me
the important thing is is the content so
I don't care really if I my face is in
the video it's very easy for people like
Michael at Vsauce and and Destin to just
have a talking head when they get to
something really hard when they get to
something they don't have a picture for
us and then they can't really visualize
they'll just show their face and say
blah blah blah blah blah and to me
that's an easy way out and it a lot of
times I'm really jealous of them but at
the same time I get I get challenged by
that and I have to figure out and that's
that's the part that I it's both
challenging but really satisfying to
have to figure out how can I visualize
this thing that I have no idea
like when I just think off the top of my
head how am I gonna visualize it now
there are some there are four
like I've been hang around with
youtubers like Derek veritasium or
Destin and and Michael Vsauce everyone
recognizes them you walk around and
people on the street even sometimes go
up and say hey you're that guy from the
internet right and I have never had this
happen which in many ways is nice but
other times you know like you get free
ice cream out of it and stuff so people
recognize you and they're like hey I
recognize you you come into my store
whoa you know come into my house or
whatever in this in this case I don't
get that so it has it has its benefits
and its drawbacks but also I don't feel
like I'm very good on camera maybe I
just need practice but I'm not uh I'd
rather be I'd rather be explaining
people and showing them visuals that
that help convey the the message in the
science rather than showing my face
sincerely a collection of Adams known as
Henry
[Music]